dr stephen r c hicks is professor of
philosophy at rockford university
illinois usa
executive director of the center for
ethics and entrepreneurship and senior
scholar at the atlas society
he received his bachelor's and master's
degrees from the university of guelph in
canada and his phd in philosophy from
indiana university bloomington usa
he's published four books translated
into 16 different languages
in 2004 and expanded in 2011 he
published explaining post-modernism
skepticism and socialism from rousseau
to foucault
in 2010 he published nietzsche and the
nazis
in 1995 with the second edition in 1998
he published the art of reasoning
readings for logical analysis co-edited
with david kelly
and he published
what year was entrepreneurial living
published 16
2016. in 2016 he published
entrepreneurial living
co-edited with jennifer harrell
he's also published in academic journals
such as business ethics quarterly
teaching philosophy and review of
metaphysics as well as other
publications such as the wall street
journal cato unbound and the baltimore
sun
in 2010 he won his university's
excellence in teaching award
he has been visiting professor of
business ethics at georgetown university
in washington dc
a visiting fellow at the social
philosophy and policy center in bowling
green ohio
senior fellow at the objectivist center
in new york
and visiting professor at the university
of kashmir the great in poland
dr hick's work on post-modernism
explaining post-modernism skepticism and
socialism from russo to foucault that's
the 2011 book
that in particular has been quite
controversial so i thought we'd open
with that
good thanks for having me you you
published explaining post-modernism
in 2011 in the revised version
how's it been selling first of all
what sort of reaction are you garnering
uh yeah sales have been steady which is
gratifying for an academic book and then
in the last i would say three to four
years sales have picked up again just
because
post-modernism has spilled out from
being a primarily intellectual movement
to a more broadly cultural movement
as a result of that i'd say the
reactions have been strongly polarized
particularly among
philosophers the reactions tend to be
positive as we talk with intellectuals
outside of the area of philosophy the
reactions start to become
more mixed uh to outright hostile
and then uh
also interestingly among the broadly
thinking public there's been
a lot of response to it so all of that's
been been gratified again of course the
reactions are
polarized because post-modernism is a
very strong vigorous movement that makes
them very
audacious in my view destructive claims
and then as we're seeing when they spill
out into the cultural arena
uh people realize the stakes are high
and we have the usual kinds of social
media debates that we have then i'm
going to do something terrible here
i'm going to start again i'm sorry my my
uh
my recorder my audio recorder wasn't
functioning
okay
so
well that way i'll get the i'll get the
intro right anyways with the with 2016
so that'll be some small benefit to
doing it and it's only about five extras
so apologies for that no problem that's
our warm-up
so
in 2016
there we go entrepreneurial living
co-edited with jennifer harrell
all right
so
we'll start that again
stephen r.c hicks is professor of
philosophy at rockford university
illinois usa
executive director of the center for
ethics and entrepreneurship
and senior scholar at the atlas society
he received his bachelor's and master's
degree from the university of guelph in
canada and his phd in philosophy from
indiana university bloomington usa
he's published four books translated
into 16 different languages
in 2004 and expanded in 2011 he
published explaining post-modernism
skepticism and socialism from rousseau
to foucault
in 2010
nietzsche and the nazis
in 1994 with the second edition in 1998
he published the art of reasoning
readings for logical analysis co-edited
with david kelly
and in 2016 entrepreneurial living
co-edited with jennifer herrell
he's published in academic journals such
as business ethics quarterly teaching
philosophy and review of metaphysics as
well as other publications such as the
wall street journal cato unbound and the
baltimore sun
in 2010
he won his university's excellence in
teaching award
dr hicks has been visiting professor of
business ethics at georgetown university
in washington dc
a visiting fellow at the social
philosophy and policy center in bowling
green ohio senior fellow at the
objectivist center in new york and
visiting professor at the university of
kashmir the great poland
so welcome today and thank you very much
for agreeing to talk with me again well
thanks for having me back
yeah it's a real pleasure
um i thought we might start by talking
about
explaining postmodernism again your 2011
book skepticism and socialism from
rousseau to foucault
because i know that it's been
perhaps more controversial of late than
it was when you originally published it
i'm so curious about the sales and the
the academic and the public reaction
right well sales have been strong the
book was originally published in 2004
installed sold steadily for the first
decade or so which is quite gratifying
for
for an academic book
um
and then starting about three years ago
in part because post-modernism started
to spill out of the strictly academic
intellectual world into the broader
cultural world
sales picked up again and so there's
been
of a two-front set of discussions one at
the intellectual level and one at the
more public thinking public level as
well
i
gratifyingly lots of translations uh i
think there will be three more
translations added this year
arabic hebrew and estonian
are in the works so uh all together i'm
pleased with that
the the reactions are quite polarized in
part because reactions to post-modernism
itself are polarized it's a it's an
extreme movement as
a good
deep thinking should be even if i
disagree fundamentally with
post-modernism it is a well articulated
negative outlook on most of life's
philosophical questions and so we should
expect
that any movement that pushes buttons
fundamentally like that should
get some extreme reactions and the same
thing holds when for me when i push back
against in my book some of these strong
to my mind ultimately nihilistic claims
that post-modernism ends up making i
also get the the negative pushback the
pushback uh kind of comes in two forms
i've found from the professional reviews
they've been h to my knowledge by
professional philosophers in the
philosophy journals and they are
generally strong to very strongly
positive the normal scholarly quibbles
arise
when i get pushback from sorry reviews
from academics outside of the philosophy
they tend to be more polarized some
strongly in favor
but then particularly people in history
in sociology in in rhetoric studies and
literature
places where there are stronger
contingents of postmodern thinkers i
tend to get uh strongly negative
responses and those responses are also
mirrored in the general thinking public
uh uh uh uh when they respond and write
back and write reviews maybe it would be
useful
to bring people up to date for you to
give us a brief
overview of your view of post-modernism
like a definition it's one of those
tricky
terms like existentialism or
phenomenology that are bandied about by
people educated people on a fairly
regular basis but
right
where the the definition itself is
slippery and difficult to pin down so
right talk a little bit about how you
view post-modernism and also what
argument you made with regards to the
history of its development right
well it makes sense that it's slippery
in part because post-modernism
philosophically uh avoids
categorizations avoids broad sweeping
statements although they do make some
so anytime you try to make a precise
broad sweeping claim about what this
post-modernism amounts to you will get
pushback on that but
there is a broadly unifying set of
themes to post-modernism if you start by
breaking the term down it's
post-modernism so first you have to say
what is modernism such that
post-modernism is reacting against it or
saying that we need to go beyond and
modernism is used variously in different
fields there's modernism in art in
literature i'm using a philosophical and
historical
understanding of postmodernism and
that's how
it's mostly used now that is to say we
look at the modern world so that
essentially is the last four to five
hundred years of history at least in the
in the western tradition so
what's going on in
the world 500 years ago is a a
revolutionary transformation of
western society we have columbus
crossing the ocean and so we're entering
into a new era of of globalization the
renaissance is uh in full swing and its
impact uh late 1400s early 1500s is now
being felt all over europe uh there is
the protestant reformation and the
counter reformation so religious life in
the west is being dramatically
transformed you see
the beginnings of science with thinkers
like copernicus and vesalius in anatomy
and so scientific method is being
developed and all of the things that we
now recognize as the scientific
disciplines are being founded so that's
the the modern world starting four or
five hundred years ago
philosophically uh we start looking at
the analyses that are being offered by
thinkers like
francis bacon
rene descartes and others and we see
that they are putting
thought on a different foundation from
that that had gone on earlier well it
seems that what happened with them well
what happened with the modernists
maybe if we tried to sum it up is that
it seemed to be this emerging consensus
that the world was rationally
intelligible yes and that human beings
could explore both physically and
mentally
and also come to predict and control
the the transformations of the material
world i mean it seems to me that that's
the fundamental element of let's say the
scientific and therefore also the
modernist perspective but but also i
think that what went along with that was
the idea that
progress
genuine progress in knowledge was
possible and along with that
the benefits of progress both
conceptually and technologically and i
mean it seems to me to be it seems to me
to be fair to point out
that
that movement bore substantive fruit i
mean
yes argue about the misery that the
modernist movement caused along the way
say with regards to the advancement of
military technology and so forth but it
seems indisputable to me that
the average human being is far better
off now than
he or she was
well certainly 200 years ago and
absolutely 500 years ago
right so
this revolution in thought with the
subsequent developments in science and
technology we certainly can judge
philosophies by their fruits
uh and so we can then say absolutely
we're living longer we're living
healthier we're living less pain free
life we're able to enjoy
more art more leisure and so forth all
of the things that again this is a value
judgment if you think those are all good
things
then we're doing a whole lot better as a
result of of that philosophy
now the other side though i want to to
emphasize here is that
you emphasize the
uh
that the world is rationally
intelligible
that along with modernism came the claim
that it was rationally intelligible to
each individual rather than there being
an elect number of people who have
special cognitive insights into the
mysteries of the universe or
that there are certain authoritative
institutions that are controlled by
elites
and only they are the ones who have
cognitive and therefore social authority
to make various pronouncements part and
parcel of the rise of modernism is a
broadly
universalizing of that that each
individual is born with a rational
capacity and that with proper training
education literacy and so forth they can
come to understand the world for
themselves they can be self-responsible
they can take charge of their lives and
as a result of that we should have an
extension of rights that used to be
prerogatives only of the few an
expansion of freedom uh you can do
whatever you want with your life broadly
speaking and so what we then see is that
it's not only a religious elite or a
political elite that is empowered but
rather every human being and then we can
see systematically over the course of
the next century it gets extended to
not only males who own property but to
all males and then to women and then to
people of other ethnicities and other
races as we push back against all of
that so we have this notion of universal
rights and universal self-responsibility
universal freedom that i think also is
part and parcel of the modern movement
well the thing about science that makes
it so peculiar i think is that science
is actually
a technology
that enables people who are
bright but not that bright let's say
to genuinely produce advances in
knowledge because of the method
right i mean if you're if you're a
careful scientist
look when we study what predicted
academic uh achievement
for example both in graduate school and
among faculty members
creativity didn't even enter the
equation
that was interesting
conscientiousness but i think it's
partly because
with the scientific method you can you
can actually break down your knowledge
seeking into a set of implementable
technological steps and that enables it
to be
implemented on an incredibly broad scale
and even if a lot of it is
error written which is obviously the
case and to a scandalous degree to
somewhat lately it still means that as
hundreds of thousands of us and
increasingly now millions of us
grind away slowly at this
careful technology of knowledge
acquisition that
overall we do seem to be able to predict
him to control the world better and then
that started to become
question you know one of the things that
seemed to characterize post-modernism
one definition that i've read is
skepticism of meta-narratives right
that's sorry that's from jean-francois
leotard and
he is the one credited with labeling
post-modernism philosophically right so
and defining it as a skepticism toward
metanarratives now what that means uh
there's a couple of things built into
that one is of course the skepticism
and philosophy
for the last century and a half or so
has entered an increasingly
skeptical mode
so that pushes back against the very
broad claims that the early modernists
are
making
that the power of reason is great it is
highly competent and that essentially we
can figure out all of the important
truths of the world we can come up with
a big story that explains everything
ultimately not necessarily that any one
individual will contain all of that
knowledge in his or her mind but
certainly communally there are
we'll have a huge amount of knowledge we
will slowly as you're putting it
together piece together a big picture
story about the way the world works and
then in principle there's there's
nothing about the universe that we can't
figure out they're just things that we
haven't been able to figure out yet so
the skepticism that leotard and the
others are talking about is a skepticism
about that grand set of claims right a
meta narrative a narrative that
encompasses
everything
uh instead we're left with smaller
narratives and then as the movement
develops we should be skeptical even
about the truth status or the the the
the knowledge status of those smaller
narratives
so
what
becomes important in the post-modern
tradition is a
skepticism about our ability to know the
world
uh and in milder form as much as the
modern thinkers thought we could and in
stronger post-modern form at all that
maybe there is no such thing as truth no
such thing as knowledge instead all we
have is opinions and beliefs that are
subjectively held but don't have any
objective consensus
the post-modernists that were influenced
by so sewer for example
they seem to be convinced in some
strange way
of something that disturbed me
when i first really discovered
dictionaries when i was a kid
you know i'd look up a word dictionary
and of course it would just refer to
another word in the dictionary and that
would refer to another word in the
dictionary and yes in some sense any
definition outside of the dictionary and
the french intellectuals that were so
um influential in the post-modern world
seem to think of meaning in exactly that
way they exactly understand that
linguistic meaning
is necessarily embedded in a larger
linguistic context so that each word is
dependent on each phrase and each phrase
is dependent on each sentence and so
there's a contextual dependency
absolutely
on linguistic framing but they seem to
me to
and and this is one of the major
problems i think of post-modernism in
university is that they seem to
deny or ignore
the existence of any world whatsoever
outside of linguistic construction
and that's that's something that strikes
me as extraordinarily curious that that
like it's a real denial of nature in my
estimation but also something
tremendously dangerous because
while assuming that you think that
physics and biology and chemistry
actually have any sort of genuine
reality it denies
the existence of a substrate of
existence that the
purely linguistic relates to i mean i
always think of words as being
they're not so much descriptions there
are tools that you use to like and
that's a victin stanion idea is that
words are really tools that you use to
operate
on the world with and the consequences
of those operations are actually
manifest in the world of sensation and
perception and emotion and motivation
and embodiment rather than purely
on a linguistic level and so i also
don't really understand how it could be
that our intellectuals could come to the
conclusion that our
and it seems like a primarily french
idea that
our ideas are are primarily constructed
linguistically i mean
how do animals exist under those
circumstances
yeah
now that strong form of linguistic
skepticism that you're articulating is
most pronounced in jacques derrida and
he does bill himself as a post
structuralist and that's a linguistic
version of of post-modernism
but the the challenge here is that
uh our view is that consciousness is
a relational phenomenon right it's
responsive to an external world
and that should be the fundamental
realist commitment that we make
the problem that the the
post-structuralists are coming up with
by the time we get to derrida i should
say
the idea that there isn't any sort of
ontological substrate matching onto not
all of the postmodernists will buy into
that as strongly as dairy dodd does they
might say well there's something out
there but we just can't know
what the relationship is between our
concepts and uh our words and an
external reality
so the point though is that the words
that we use are abstractions and they do
come along fairly far uh or high up in
our cognitive development and uh if you
want to argue that consciousness is a
response to reality or that
consciousness is a relational phenomenon
as i do to maintain that objective
relational commitment there what you
then have to do is take up all of the
skeptical
arguments that want to
put consciousness out of relationship or
to say that there's no way to bridge
this gap between the subject and the
object once you start going down that
road uh if you want to say for example
that perception is fraught with
illusions or hallucinations or that we
can't tell the difference between
a vertical
perception when our our sensory organs
are in contact with reality and a
hallucination well then you have a gap
between our conscious apparatus and
reality if you then want to go on and
argue as empiricists do
that our concepts and the words that we
assign to the concepts are based on
empirical observations or perceptual
observations but you now believe that
those perceptual observations are are
subjective and out of relation with
objective reality
then you're going to say these abstract
concepts and words are also out of
relation with reality and then what
gives them their meaning if you can't
establish a connection between the words
and reality then you're into the
dictionary you're saying what gives the
words their meaning is their sideways or
network connections to other words and
then a generation or two later you're
into deroda's university where he says
language is all of reality
that's also where the postmodernists
claim about the primacy of power seem to
sneak in
it's like well if the words are only
related to one another
in terms of their verbal relationship
well they don't seem to have any motive
force and
as soon as you enter a landscape of
linguistic consideration that has no
motive force then there's nothing to do
and so
this seems to me to account for like
i've been criticized very often for
let's say conflating post-modernism and
marxism but it seems to me that the
marxists or that the post-modernists
have had to default to what are
essentially marxist preconceptions to
add any motive to their thinking and
what they've done is to say that well
words are related to one another and
that's how they derive their fundamental
meaning and they're not really connected
to the world in any real way except in
so far as they privilege
one group or another or one person other
in terms of power and status which
exactly so to go back to your dictionary
analysis the next step then would be to
say
if words are in these linguistic
relationships to other words and we can
find out what they are in dictionaries
well who
writes the dictionaries
and then at that point you're not asking
a an epistemological question anymore
you are asking a social and
psychological question so who are the
authors of the dictionary what author
authorizes rather than with the power to
decide what words mean
at that point uh we stepped directly out
of the kind of narrow epistemological
arguments uh into social and
psychological arguments about linguistic
communities so
that's another go ahead
because well
look if
if the words only have meaning in
relationship to one another and there's
this gap between the words and empirical
reality which by the way i don't think
anybody disputes i mean that's why we
need five senses that's why we need to
communicate with each other that's why
we need the scientific method right is
because it's difficult to establish a
useful one-to-one relationship between
words and reality but if words serve
power
then it seems to me that what the
post-modernists have done is
taken
biological
motivation let's call it the motivation
for power at least
and and sneaked it through the back door
and
and reconnected the world of linguistic
abstraction to the world of reality but
saying well look
the only connection is one of power and
then they leave why it is that people
want power like
the idea that people want power first of
all is a complicated idea because you
have to define power and you have to
define what and
those aren't trivial issues by any
stretch of the imagination
and so you you you sneak it in the back
door as sort of self-evident and then
that seems to undermine the general
post-modernist claim it's like if it's
if the words are only embedded in a
network of meaning that's related to
other words
it isn't a fair move
ontologically or epistemologically
to
reinsert
power striving like a nietzsche and
powers driving or even an adlerian power
striving as the fundamental and
what would you call it sort of swede
generous motivation that characterizes
human beings so i also don't understand
how they get away with that except that
it seems to be like a mask for the
continuation of a marxist move under new
guys
well i have no problem with seeing power
as a positive right
coming back to just in a moment to all
of the
suspicions that you're announcing about
inappropriate understandings of the
relationship of power i do think we
should be able to say
our cognitive capacities are a power
that we have
and we they are a tool and the whole
point of using that tool is to increase
our power in the world to achieve our
goals
what the postmoderns are doing is
undercutting the two things that make
that understanding of power legitimate
one is to say that when i am making a
cognitive claim i am uh successfully
saying something about the world so that
we can use the words knowledge and truth
so if i want to act on the basis of my
beliefs uh that those beliefs do map
onto world as it really is but if you
are skeptical about any sort of a
knowledge claim uh or any sort of a
truth claim then you're just going to
say no no your claims merely are
subjective uh
beliefs that are peculiar to you or
peculiar to your group and they don't
have any special cognitive status
whatsoever
and in that case if you want to act on
or use those beliefs to empower you well
then you are in an out of reality
connection
now the other thing is we want to say
that power
should be a tool that we use for good
for advancing genuine values in the
world but another part of the
post-modern skepticism is to say that we
cannot ground any values objectively
instead values are merely subjective
preferences either individually or group
oriented and so in that case if you have
your value framework then we're into the
problem of relativism and i have my
value framework neither of us is able to
induce any facts that give an objective
grounding to those values or to argue
that those values should be universally
embraced then we're just left with you
have a certain amount of power to
advance your interest i have a certain
amount of power to advance my interests
and it's a naked power struggle in the
suspicious way that you're worried about
and that is
uh uh we come back to this issue of how
marxist or not the postmoderns are
but you're right that at least the great
grandfather move right was made by the
marxists in one generation and the
nietzschean's next generation to strip
power down to that amoral uh uh
ontological status that you are worried
about but but what's the motivation for
it it's like if there isn't uh reality
that's outside the linguistic
then why is it
why is it that well first of all what is
well i think there's two yeah i think
there are two kinds of motivations one
of the
one of the things we know is that there
are people who just like power they want
to control other people they have their
agendas now we can talk about the
sociological and the psychological
foundations of that but that is an
ongoing fact about society some people
just want power and they will then
rationalize
their use of power over other people by
a variety of means okay so we're willing
to that's that's
that's one that is an extra linguistic
reality
yes the thing that's so surprising to me
it's like i'm not disputing that
right if you think of the way some
lawyers argue in a courtroom uh
they will use all sorts of retal
rhetorical power plays they will make
fallacious arguments if they can get
away with it they will brow beat
witnesses and make up facts and so forth
now they are not really skeptical they
believe that there's an external world
and so forth they just believe that life
is a power struggle and any tactic is
fair in order to achieve their ends
right so they're not post modernist
lawyers they're just old-fashioned
power-seeking lawyers and so forth now
that is one motivation it comes up in
religious circles it comes up in
political circles it comes up in the
school yard uh and so on but the other
one and the one that i think that we are
worried about though is that those who
get to that view
about the amoral ontological
substrate uh being power
are those people who are smart and uh
who
do some thinking about philosophy
thinking about politics and so forth and
they argue themselves into that position
because they find the
power of those skeptical arguments to be
convincing rationally to them so even
though this is not a paradoxical
formulation even though they are
rational individuals they are following
the logic of certain skeptical arguments
to its conclusion and the legitimate
conclusion of those arguments is that a
moral power rules the universe
okay so so let's let's examine that for
a moment i mean
this is another thing that that strikes
me as as
specious to say the least i mean first
of all i'm very skeptical of people who
try to
reduce all complex phenomena to a single
explanatory mechanism
you know i mean if you look at because i
do look at things biologically it's
obvious that human beings have a
multitude of primordial motivational
systems and that we share them and that
we share them with animals there's pain
and there's fear and there's incentive
reward and there's rage and there's play
and there's hunger and there's lust and
that's a handful that there's more than
that and these are very and you know
those
motivations get integrated across time
into
hyper motivations let's say
that would be something akin to an
integrated
narrative one that
is manifested interpersonally but also
played out socially and higher order
values emerge from that
um
you take a claim like the postmodernist
make that well first of all they accept
the idea that there's almost nothing but
hierarchy and that people's fundamental
motivations is to climb up the hierarchy
even though they're very
my experiences being for example
whenever i talk about hierarchy the
post-modernist types go after me
hammer and tongs
because i'm making the claim that
hierarchy is a natural phenomenon not
necessarily a beneficial one but an
inevitable one in some sense with its
pros and cons but they accept that
uncritically when they presume that
power is the fundamental drive
and then
the other
problem is and this is an even more
serious one as far as i'm concerned is
that the evidence
that the most effective way
for human beings to
occupy
positions of authority let's say and
competence
in
human dominance hierarchies isn't
through the naked expression of power
that's actually unbelievably unstable
you know even france to wall when he was
studying chimpanzees you know
the female chimpanzees are more
empathetic than the male chimpanzees
but of all the chimpanzees the alpha
males are the most empathic they're the
ones that engage in the most reciprocal
interactions with the members of the
troop
and the there's and there's evidence
accruing from all sorts of areas
including developmental psychology the
developmental psychology of piaget for
example that suggests that
like
something like
cooperative game playing aimed towards a
particular important end
is a much more stable means for
establishing
hierarchical relationships between
people than power it's like
power only rules
in tyrannies and then i guess maybe
that's part of the reason that the
postmodernists also insist that the
western hierarchy is fundamentally an
oppressive patriarchy because that
justifies their claim that power is the
primary
motivator and mover of the world but i
just don't see how that's a tenable
position
yeah
well uh
i think ontologically it's fair to say
that most postmoderns
buy into the notion that power is
fundamental there's not anything that
can be reduced to that but then my
reading of them is that that is not the
entire philosophical story because power
just is a
a tool a means to an end and it still
leaves open the question of
what ends to which one is going to use
that power and here i think the
postmoderns are
rightly diverse in their views
there is a strong streak of them and
this is something that goes back to
marxism in general or broadly socialism
in general that will say
yes we all want power but we recognize
that power is unequally distributed in
the world and that connects to your
points about hierarchy but what is your
value reaction to that unequal
distribution of power in the world
now there are the nichians who will
react to say well the unequal
distribution of power uh is fine and our
sympathies are with those who have more
power because we want them to
advance the human species by some
evolutionary mechanism
but that is a subjective value
preference that they are adding to two
previous facts that power is fundamental
that power is unequally distributed now
we're adding my sympathies are with
those who have more power
the socialist or
more narrowly marxist responsible is to
say
power is fundamental power is unequally
distributed but our empathy is with
those who are on the losing side of
history so to speak or of various sorts
of social forces and so what that then
means for them is that they will accept
that power is operating in a
hierarchical context but that they want
to use whatever power they have to more
uh equally redistribute the power in a a
in a uh in an
egalitarian fashion right so what we
need
to talk about is going to be though that
third component about what your value
reaction is to what you take to be the
metaphysical uh substrate right okay but
then there's there's another form of
real world smuggling that goes along
with that which is both
ontological and ethical
and the ontological smuggling would be
well there are definitely power
structures and that people compete for
power so that's claim number one which
seems to be extra linguistic
and claim number two is that
the proper moral stance of a human being
is empathy so there's a claim that
something like empathy exists and that
empathy should be reserved for people
who are on the
lower end of the hierarchical
distribution that's right okay and
postmoderns like foucault make that very
clear uh richard rorty uh even more
clearly
uh makes that claim
uh jacques derrida is a very interesting
case because most of his work is uh not
overtly social ethical or political
but at various points particularly
toward the end of his life he says you
know my my entire sympathies are with
the oppressed and he talks about
reinvigorating a certain kind or in the
spirit of marxism something or other
but
from his perspective he recognizes that
he has no philosophical resources to
justify
that value claim and he doesn't want to
say that it's just a personal subjective
preference that he has so he does appeal
to a kind of kantian regulative idea or
uh what in more old-fashioned way that
it's a kind of platonic form
that that we need to appeal to if we're
going to justify it in some way so it's
kind of interesting that
recognizing exactly the problem that
you're pointing out where do we get that
empathy claim from and justify that the
postmoderns
recognize the predicament and some of
them are trying to point to extra
linguistic sources for it well that
opens that opens a big can of worms if
your initial claim is that there's no
such thing as an extra linguistic source
exactly well because you let one extra
linguistic source and especially
something as complicated as the
interplay between
say power hierarchy and empathy i mean
yes those are major
motivational forces and
and then if you're willing to admit to
the existence of those major
motivational forces well it's it's hard
to exclude pain
it's hard to exclude anxiety it's hard
to exclude or something even more basic
is hunger
it's hard to exclude uh the proclivity
for cooperation and play it's like all
of biology it seems to me sneaks back
into the postmodern project as soon as
those initial extra linguistic realities
were allowed
well absolutely but that's what we're
finding uh a lot of our debates are
right now about psychology and biology
uh is that a certain number of
psychologists and biologists are pushing
back and saying oh there is a reality
here but we're getting great resistance
from the post-modern second and third
generation to having to do so
okay so now you said the philosophers
that have reviewed your book
have been basically positive and so yes
why
are you receiving
positive feedback from
what is it about philosophy and about
philosophers or about your work that's
eliciting a positive response from them
yeah
well my book is primarily an
intellectual history you know to some
extent i am polemical and pushing back
against postmodernism so people
understand that i'm taking a stance as
well
but the primary purpose of the book is
to do a solid intellectual history where
does this confusing sprawling but
nonetheless very vigorous and powerful
movement come from
and it doesn't come out of thin air but
rather there's a lot of deep thinking
that's behind it
so what i'm doing is i'm tracing what i
see as the important intellectual
movements of the last two centuries
so i'm starting with content russo i'm
talking about hegel marx nietzsche
heidegger and the others
so
uh
all of those figures are
difficult complex and important in their
own right and their scholarly debate
about say how skeptical or not kant is
whether there's an element of liberalism
or not in nietzsche uh heidegger's
connection to the nazis and so forth uh
so there is a range of scholarly
movement and most of these major
intellectuals have two or three major
schools of interpretation attached to
them
but what a and so the pushback that i am
getting uh on kant or on nietzsche or
heidegger or whatever will be
from those who are in a different school
of interpretation with respect to them
but typically among the philosopher it's
a respectful engagement because they
will recognize that there is a very good
argument that can be made for
interpreting the philosopher the other
way
uh and typically then what i'm doing is
emphasizing the skeptical elements or
the ultimately negative and nihilistic
elements that get sifted out and woven
together
into ultimately the uh the postmodern
framework and along the way the
philosophers who want to argue well you
know this particular thinker is not that
bad or he would not buy into the whole
project those are the ones who will
criticize me on various things
what i typically find though outside of
philosophical circles though is and that
this is not a criticism of these
individuals since we can't know
everything
is that they
uh will know something about nietzsche
or heidegger or or kant but they're not
up on the scholarly literature you know
they've read one book or one article
about that person that was written from
a certain perspective so if i make the
argument for the other perspective on
that thinker it's new to them and it
seems outrageous to them and so they
will react
negatively to it
so something like that
so now you wrote this book back in 2004
so you were pretty early observer of
the
vital importance i suppose of the
post-modernist debate i mean there's
certainly been a
rise in political correctness in the
early 90s and that's it disappear by the
mid 90s but
2004 is i would say five or six or maybe
even
eight years
previous to the
to this new
burgeoning of
political polarization and
and the debate
between the politically correct types
let's say and those who take a more
biological perspective it's like what
clued you into the fact that this was a
issue of fundamental of potentially
fundamental importance
yeah
well yeah thanks um i think it does a
testament to the power of philosophy the
power of ideas the power of logic
that when you identify abstract
principles and their adoption
and you have a good sense of logic you
can make predictions about how they're
going to play out when they are applied
in real life
this is one of my
major career beliefs that philosophy
is not
disembodied abstract head in the clouds
but no matter how abstract
and speculative various philosophical
positions
uh seem to be
when they are believed and acted upon
the
they make a real life difference so in
part that's what i was doing i actually
wrote the first draft of the book uh 20
years ago this year in 1999 i had a
sabbatical and so i uh i had an outline
of the book written in 1999
and then by the middle part of the year
2000 i had
fully written the book but it didn't
come out until 2004 because i had some
challenges with getting getting it
published
um but i think what has happened in the
last five years or so is that we're now
into second or third generation
post-modernism depending on how you
count things
and what has happened is
the the first generation of postmoderns
were very successful
inside academic circles at educating
large numbers of students getting a
significant number of them
through graduate school and then to
themselves becoming professors and
public intellectuals and things reached
a critical mass i would say starting six
or seven years ago
and so then we started to notice it
significantly starting to transform the
internal
dynamics of the university but we also
now have a critical mass of activists
who are now graduated maybe they didn't
graduate with phds they got bachelor's
degrees or master's degrees but they've
gone into activist organizations
and they are trying to and then
successfully shifting the terms of the
debate
uh
outside of the academic world and so the
broader public starts to notice things
uh and then
well that's where we are right now with
uh the culture war manifesting itself on
two major fronts the academic world and
the broader cultural space right well so
what are your concerns about that like
when you look out at the world
um
you're obviously concerned enough about
post-modernist thinking to devote a
substantial proportion of your academic
career to it and then to put yourself on
the line to some degree as well
what is it about the post-modernist view
that
well let's let's let's ask this question
two ways
what do you think
the advantages
if any are to the postmodernist view or
the inevitability of it and what do you
think the dangers and disadvantages are
um well that's yeah two two big
questions first why why i'm worried
about it uh and there's a question about
what degree of worry right one should
have
interestingly in my home discipline of
philosophy post-modernism is not that
strong
i think part of the philosophy
flirted with and
post-modernism for a while i think
philosophy did generate all of the
arguments or at least all the major
arguments that post-moderns use a
philosophy does have built into its dna
so to speak a very healthy respect for
argumentation
and
a liking for new arguments so what has
happened mostly in the philosophy
profession is a serious development and
engagement with all of these negative
skeptical arguments and so on but then a
realization that a lot of them don't
work in various ways and then people
moving off in other directions
or once we start seeing the same
arguments being recycled and retreading
a certain amount of boredom occurs with
it because you know smart active minded
people like new things and so someone
comes along with a new
positive argument or a new positive
program and philosophers get excited
about that and so post-modernism is
a little bit passe in those disciplines
but i am worried about it because
philosophy uh demographically is a tiny
proportion of the overall
academy and the post-modern arguments
have been
picked up by the larger and more
influential academic disciplines such as
psychology right you know this one as
well english literature to some extent
in the law schools in the field of
history sociology is very polluted and
then the the big rise of all of the uh
the various special studies programs you
know gender studies race studies
ethnicity studies and so on you find a
much higher percentage of post-modernism
there
now uh i have not seen good
journalistic sociology about higher
academics you know whether it's eight
percent or forty percent of people who
are post-modern or not
but there clearly is an uptick a
statistically significant uh increase in
the number of people who are adopting
post-modern viewpoints and then
educating the next generation of
students
yes
among the activist types
yeah absolutely yes that's right so
uh there is a this is a
non-philosophical issue this is a
journalistic or a demographical issue
about measuring to what extent it's a
rising movement how widespread it is and
so on and my concern professionally is
with the arguments that generate
post-modernism and refuting those now
why this is important is uh well you
know i'm a professor so i'm always
dealing with young people who are at the
early stages of their their careers and
in my view the most important thing uh
that we all need
as human beings we're thoughtful people
we want to be passionately engaged with
the world we want our lives to be
meaningful is we do need a philosophy of
life that's going to
set us up for
uh the best chance of succeeding in our
lives as possible so in my view i'm
basically an optimist we do
need
as young people
with our whole lives ahead to have some
sense that my life is going to be
meaningful it's going to be significant
that there are important values that i
can strive for
uh
the romantic in me wants to say my life
can and should be this great adventure
and
having that fundamental commitment and
helping students sort out what are the
genuine values that are worth pursuing
in life
that has to be uh instilled in young
people otherwise they will just drift
through life and then they will get to
their older years and and realize that
their their life is further away
yes okay so that's an interesting now
that's very interesting observation
because you know
i've been trying to account at least in
part for
well let's say the
surprising and surreal popularity of my
public lectures
so absolutely
about 150 cities now to about 300 000
people and you know i lay out a fairly
straightforward case i would say that's
very much analogous to
the case that you just described
and that is that
well
we look for some unassailable truths
and for me
there are two unassailable pessimistic
truths
and one is that
a substantial proportion of life is
going to be suffering because we're
finite and even if things are going well
for you now
you're subject to illness mental and
physical you're subject to the
decimation of your dreams you're going
to lose the people that you love the
world that you know is going to change
in ways that you find
disconcerting and unfortunate and so
suffering's built in and then
if you don't mind me uh interrupting at
that point the the the phrase
unassailable truth i mean what we should
be doing though in education is
saying that there are no
unassailable truths that part of a good
education is
any previous generation's truth should
be assailed at least intellectually by
the students they should challenge
question and look at those truths what
the best arguments can be mounted
against them and then make their own
judgments about whether they agree that
this truth is in fact a truth or whether
it needs to be rejected and and moved on
so the great danger i think of
post-modernism though is its
skeptical stance toward the idea of
there being truth at all
and then in its activist manifestation
when the professors are functioning as i
just have my subjective preferences and
i have power in the classroom and my
view as a professor or my practice
rather as a professor is simply to
indoctrinate students in my subjective
preferences
in that case what you are doing is not
only giving students a very cynical
negative ultimately
empty view of the world but you are not
at all training them in the ability to
think for themselves to compare
competing viewpoints and make their own
judgment so that's the danger
right right well i guess
i should i should reconsider my
use of the word unassailable
i'm thinking more i was thinking more i
suppose clinically in some sense and
that
my experience has been that you don't
have to scratch very deeply beneath the
surface of people's lives right until
you find yeah and i know yes
they're dealing with and
so i don't know i know you're not saying
this but from the students perspective
it can't be that professor peterson with
all of his years of experience and
wisdom has announced that this is a
truth therefore it's a truth
they have to go through the process that
you went through hopefully you can
accelerate that process
for them but they have to go through
that process yeah well and i mean i do
that in the lectures by telling stories
too and
and and illustrating the fact that you
know the the limitations that are placed
on us that produce
suffering and i invite people i would
say to draw their own conclusions about
how they regard
that reality in their own lives and
the second proposition let's say
is that the suffering is often made
worse by malevolence and that can be
well this sort of
what would you say impersonal
malevolence of nature or the more
personal malevolence of society or the
individual and so we're faced with that
set of problems
that that vulnerability that's
characteristic of existence and then
that
that vulnerability because it
constitutes a real set of problems calls
to us to generate solutions and
it's in that
attempt to generate solutions that that
adventure that you described earlier
seems to me to manifest itself and so it
seems reasonable to me to
to suggest to young people that they do
have a destiny that gives their life
significant individual import and that
is to
take arms up against the
inequities of existence at
whatever levels they can and to act
forthrightly and courageously to
minimize unnecessary suffering and to
constrain malevolence and that and that
it's also
it is also actually a vital importance
that they do that because their
their failure to do so
is more damaging than their than they
think
their nihilism and cynicism that might
entice them into
nihilistic and destructive acts
themselves actively is more destructive
than they think
and their capacity to do
positive things in the world on a large
scale individually and in their family
and in their community is much larger
than they think and i it's very
difficult for me to see
how
young people can not
can be
left uninformed of that as at least a
potential reality without falling down
the rabbit hole of nihilism and cynicism
and subjectivism and relativism that
seems to me to be at least one of the
primary dangers of post-modernism yes
yeah i think 100 on the latter part of
what you were saying i think on the
should be an open question initially
yes there is suffering in the world yes
there is malevolence in the world
uh but we should also be open to the
fact that there is pleasure
there is beauty there is romance
there is adventure uh there is genuine
love in the world
and what proportions of
uh benevolence versus malevolence
happiness versus suffering
is possible and natural to human beings
that should be part of the conversation
early on
uh i think it's it's an appropriate
initial start go ahead give your tools
i'm sorry that's a conversation about
the potency of your tools like you could
you could admit that these fundamental
limitations exist but you don't have to
draw the conclusion that they're
um
in any
manner well it's not just about the
tools it's uh also about the nature of
the reality that we are confronting
there are of course people who are
polyanists who have this view that the
world is on our side there's a
benevolent god or the forces of the
universe are lined up such that i lead a
charmed life and everything will go well
for me there are people at the other end
of the spectrum who uh you know who
argue the opposite the the fates are
against me the gods hate me no matter
what i do
the forces that govern the universe will
just grind me down that's got nothing to
do with my tool set initially so to
speak that's a metaphysical claim about
the nature of the universe
now when we do turn to the tool set uh
if
whatever your position is along the
spectrum of benevolence to malevolence
there is the question about how much
power
i have
to craft my own tools to forge myself
into the kind of being that can take on
life's challenges and here i think
post-modernism is dangerous in two
important respects uh in my view the the
most important
development of education schooling
parenting and so on
is
giving students and young people the
critical thinking the rational power to
be able to understand the world to be
able to conceptualize it to know how to
do the experiments to analyze the
results to sort out good truth claims
from [__] uh and so on and so all of
that cognitive development that can only
come from a commitment to the idea that
the evidence matters
that doing the experiments matters that
being excruciatingly honest with respect
to the to the the power of the arguments
for and against positions that one might
want to argue
or adopt but that's absolutely important
the development of a student's rational
logical critical capacity is
fundamentally important and
post-modernism is an assault on that
what that means is that in practice
students do not develop that most
important life skill and so put them out
into the world without the tools that
they need and i think they are then more
likely to feel disempowered they're more
likely to feel overwhelmed and then we
get
the angry uh despairing activist type of
person that we see in larger numbers now
if the postmodernists are concerned
ethically
with the
reestablishment of
genuine power
at the bottom of the power hierarchies
why do you think it's the case if it is
the case and many commentators have made
this case jonathan height among them
that
the doctrines that the postmodernists
tend to be teaching young people seem to
be so absolutely
infantilizing
and
undermining
rather than
strengthening and and and
and increasing resilience i mean yeah is
it is it that they're not interested
at the individual level i mean because
it seems so paradoxical that these
things are happening simultaneously
yeah a couple things on that one is uh
that in addition to developing a
person's rational capacity we do need to
develop their emotional capacity
life is a capacity for a great adventure
for great positivity but as you
emphasize there is also going to be a
significant amount of pain and suffering
uh and so what we need to do is develop
our emotional capacity for
handling all of that resilience is an
important part of that one unfortunate
part of the post-modern package though
is that they are focusing on a very
narrow range of emotions typically
negative emotions and they don't see
those emotions as having any connection
to rationality or any connection to a
response to an actual objective reality
out there so
uh
the emotional life of human beings is
both cramped and a mystery if you take
the postmodern framework seriously and
so i think what happens then is when
those postmoderns become teachers or
professors or in a position of authority
uh it's a large amount of uh emotional
communication that is going on but it's
going to be a negative rage focus
despair focus cynical jaded focused kind
of uh
emotionalism and to the extent the
students pick up on that they're going
to be like turned off or if they have
some predisposition toward that they
just get sucked into that emotional
universe
speak to uh jonathan heights point
that you're raising yeah let me just say
one thing that is striking to me is i
find it interesting among our public
intellectuals that
three of the most prominent people on
the public intellectual sphere
are your
jonathan height and stephen tinker
and all three of you are professionally
psychologists
i
don't know i think that that is
accidental because
what all three of you are doing in
different ways is
noticing that philosophy of course is a
very abstract set of arguments and
principles but all of those do need to
be operationalized in
actual living breathing human beings and
when you see how they are actually
operationalized in human beings a large
part of what you're doing is psychology
so i think it's uh
not accidental that psychologists are of
significant importance in the public
intellectual space right now
so to speak to jonathan heights point um
i think what he is uh
uh pointing out is that we are now into
a second and third generation of
postmoderns and
there's a devolution
in the
intellectual quality
of the movement and that makes sense
because if your first generation
movement is quite skeptical and
relativistic
but nonetheless very educated as rorty
derrida foucault leotard especially in
my view uh were
but the
end
conclusion of their position is that we
don't need to take rationality logic the
quest for objectivity too seriously
what will happen in the next generation
then will be
a a whole generation of
people with phds who don't take logic
rationality in the quest for objectivity
very seriously instead they will be
not developing those
skill sets at a very high level so there
will be a devolution there will be more
emphasizing emotionalism there will be
more emphasizing activism and then in
the third generation it will be a
further devolution so
uh
i don't have a huge set going like yeah
is that a self-defeating
is it something well it is
yeah it is
i think it is self-defeating
intellectually and one of the things
that uh people who are intellectuals who
have been following the arguments for a
while notice is this is just a recycling
of arguments that i heard five years ago
10 years ago 20 years ago and so it
becomes self-defeating in the sense that
it fails to attract the ongoing interest
of the smart very active-minded people i
think also that this is something built
into human nature and this is my my
great uh optimism uh with young people
when they come to university however
underprepared and damaged they might be
by their their primary and high school
education
they are nonetheless particularly i
think in north america still
uh optimistic gung-ho they believe that
they can make something of their lives
and when they start going into classes
where the professors in word and action
and just in their physical bearing are
commuting communicating rather messages
of defeatism and cynicism
students who are
psychologically healthy we'll just avoid
those classes
they will go into fields that hold some
promise of positivity for them they will
be turned into entrepreneurial fields
i'm sorry that they may avoid university
yeah absolutely sure yeah so what's the
point of uh going to uh
wallowing
uh about what a victim you are or what a
bad person you are because you have
white skin or you're a male or whatever
for four years i'm gonna quit university
and get on with living
i do think there also will be corrective
mechanisms in place uh
to some extent universities are driven
by dollars
and who is writing the big checks uh if
it's a million dollar donors when some
terrible manifestation of political
correctness happens at their institution
they won't write the million dollar
check the next year that will get
noticed and that will be communicated in
various ways so
the you know the universities have their
problems but i am
ultimately optimistic that they will be
able to heal themselves there are market
mechanisms in place to uh to
to
span okay that's interesting well it's
interesting that i mean i waver between
optimism and pessimism because i feel
that
the
the uh the strata of
postmodernists is relatively young and
relatively entrenched and protected by
tenure and of course i think 10 years a
good idea
um
but that and that they're also
unbelievably good at
fomenting activism i mean i think
political surveys indicate that only
about four percent of the general
population who views that might be
regarded as radical
marxist slash postmodern it's a tiny
minority like it's bigger than that
universities but they they swing out
they swing beyond their weight they they
hit absolutely they hit past their
weight and it's also i think because
you know serious academics
this is my impression is that serious
academics really ignored the
second-rate post-modern discipline or
decades feeling that the arguments that
they were making were
weak enough so that they didn't even
require
uh a strong rebuttal i mean even when
stephen pinker wrote his book um
the blank slate you know
i read that book and i thought
that it was an interesting book but i
thought jesus
dr pinker
no one's believed that people
are blank slates for like 30 years
that's
that it seems
as a biological psychologist it just
seemed to me to be observed that that
case had to be even made but it was
obviously right about that and i was
obviously very wrong about that
yeah predictions are uh
hard to make
and i think it goes back to we need
better journalism about the demographics
of higher education and what's going on
there so is it
four percent uh is it twelve percent is
it twenty-five percent then this issue
you're raising about punching above
their weight
uh that does seem to be true but how
much above their weight are they
punching
is the major problem in the classrooms
uh or is it a matter of you know as we
know most academics don't like committee
work yeah but a significant number of so
if the first rate people are
doing their real academic work and
they're trying to avoid committee work
but the second and third raiders they
don't mind committee work and they see
it as a vehicle to power within the
university for them
so if the postmoderns
are uh as we like to think second or
third great that's a little bit unfair
not all of them are but a higher
percentage of them doing the important
committee work then they have a certain
amount of power there
an overlooked part of the university
demographics from my perspective is
student life
where
the the residents
the people who look after the residence
hall and the entertainment and deciding
what student clubs are authorized or not
uh there's been a significant
infiltration of post-modernism in that
area that's not on the academic side or
only in indirect but if you look at
orientation programs and again we need
better journalism here but you find a
significant number of them are devoting
the whole into orientation week
when the first year students are coming
in to
lectures on privilege and oppression and
whatever the buzz words are
that also is an important uh issue as
well
uh
an article written in the chronicle of
higher education excoriating faculties
of education
for producing precisely the kinds of
internal university activists that are
pushing exactly that kind of agenda
right
yeah faculties of education i i do some
work in philosophy of education
uh they're all over the map but there
has been a significant post-modern shift
uh as with post-modernism being the
reigning philosophy of education
uh and then of course that has
impact not just in higher education
because that's training the next
generation of teachers uh one of my
younger colleagues a man named andrew
colgan recent phd from western
university of western ontario
in his discrimination was documenting
the the significant demographic shift
among ontario high school teachers
toward basically buying into a
postmodern framework and that's a going
to be a very important generational
shift for ontario
so what makes you like you talked about
market forces and the corrective ability
and
and we spoke before we started this
podcast about
about speaking about optimistic and
positive
elements and movements i mean
so well i've two questions for you at
least before we conclude and one is
you you seem optimistic and positive and
and so
what do you see as the root out of this
and and what
what will replace it and like what's the
time span
yes well i think one thing that we are
noticing is an increasing number of
first-rate people who are now engaging
the debate within higher education
so you can mention someone like
stephen pinker who's not just doing
academic psychology now and said he's
devoting resources to
defending in a public intellectual
sphere the enlightenment project
jonathan haight also excellent
psychologist doing the clinical work as
well but nonetheless is formative in
creating the heterodox academy bringing
together
uh academics from a wide variety of
political spectrum
positions but nonetheless all agreeing
that academic freedom free speech and so
forth are are important the work that
you're doing uh
stepping out under the public space
stage as well so
there is a major uptick in very good
academics
taking post-modernism and its offshoots
seriously and pushing back and i think
that augurs well
i think there also is a financial
clout i think young students when they
come in they do
take a post-modernism course but they
don't go back for more or they plug into
the student grapevine and they learn
which courses to avoid and in many cases
the post-modern activist type professors
they are really ghettoized in marginal
departments they might be outsized in
their voice but they're not attracting a
huge number of students
and in my view the students that they
are attracting are ones who are
already predisposed to the to that
they're not necessarily converting
it seems to be the least invasive way of
dealing with
postmodernism if it if it does have the
negative
attributes that we've been discussing
is actually
something like a market solution which
is to
inform young people as to it's essential
and to help convince them that there are
viable alternatives like viable
philosophical alternatives viable
political alternatives courses they
could be taking that would enrich their
lives instead of enhancing their sense
of victimization exactly that's right
like the safest route rather than
political intervention or or some kind
of attempt to radically change the
structure of the universities which
seems to be more dangerous than than
useful
and i i'm very gung-ho on the internet
the internet of course is just a tool
can be used for good or ill and there's
a lot of crap as we all know on the
internet but it also is the case that
young open-minded hungry students uh
when they are at a university and
they're not getting the education that
they want they now have access to all
sorts of viewpoints and they're actively
exploring them i'm sure you get hundreds
of contacts i get lots of contacts from
students from all over the world
uh who
come to me through the internet and i
know that that's a worldwide phenomenon
i also do think uh that there's lots of
very interesting entrepreneurial
experimentation going on in higher
education some of it's driven by the the
cost demographics you know people asking
the reasonable question is it really
worth a quarter million dollars
uh to uh to get a good higher education
at a traditional bricks and mortar
university or should i spend just a
hundred thousand dollars and maybe get
only a 75 quality education
at an online institution or some other
vehicle so there's lots of
experimentations that are going on there
and of course the technology is just
getting better and better so i think
instead of
the only avenue being taking the
universities on head-on from the inside
that battle has to be fought and some of
us are doing it but there will be a
significant number of people who will
just avoid the universities altogether
and there will be new institutions that
are created and that will be a market
solution
you know that 70 about 75
of the cumulative student debt in the
united states is held by women
i did not know that and the
disproportionate number of those women
are black
so it turns out that
it's so perverse that
they're so perverse and part of the um
explanation for that
it's not the total explanation is that
um
these
women were
enticed or chose to enter disciplines
where the probability of making enough
money over
a reasonable span of your life
especially given the high interest rates
that are associated with student debt is
extraordinarily low so that's another
strange reaction that's a perverse
unintended consequence i was not aware
of that statistic i was aware that uh
this matches with my experience that
about 60 percent of our university
graduates are women
compared to only about 40 percent male
so there's a demographic shift there so
uh
but i was not aware of the the racial
component of that yeah
very interesting unintended consequence
it's really well it's brutal you know
because these poor women are laboring
under these debt loads that it looks
like they're never going to be able to
clear okay so that's that's optimism
it's long-term optimism but it's all
and so and so that's good to hear can
can i ask you a little bit about what
your private
what your life has been like let's say
over the last couple of years
as you've
used
social media more and as your work has
become
much more
disseminated and discussed publicly yeah
the pluses and the minuses for you and
what's changed for you yeah overall
pluses
outweigh the minuses definitely uh well
the main minus has been that it's cut a
lot into my writing time
in some ways majorly i'm a
stereotypical nerd
my
ideal day is to go to the library with
my computer and read and write with a
stack of books
and i i envisioned my professor's life
as being dominated by that but certainly
for the last couple of years my my
writing and thinking time has been has
been lessened
uh the other major negative just has
been there
it's just the crap you have to put up
with with people who are on various
hobby horses who disagree with you but
who don't have
social skills or the uh to know how to
have a fruitful discussion so
they send you ad hominem emails and just
resort to insults because you you
disagree with them
uh so there's been a certain steady
stream of that but
part of my learning curve has been just
to be able to ignore that or filter that
out and focus on the
the uh
the positive responses and and the
critical responses that are raising good
questions
uh i did want to mention if i can plug i
have an open college podcast series and
i've got two
podcasts in the work where i'm taking up
the
the the serious in some cases good
criticisms that have been raised of my
work
so
i'm working on uh on those as well
and that's just part of the ongoing
fun scholarly back and forth that that
should be going on
and while i am down on post-modernism i
i should say that i do think uh
it's an important part of any person's
education
to at least for some time consider the
most skeptical and nihilistic arguments
that are out there
that post-modernism should have a seat
at the table in any person's education
uh
uh and so it really should be a three or
four-way debate that's going on there uh
and and students need to process those
arguments for themselves
the
the other pluses are that i do enjoy uh
travel so in addition to my normal
academic conferencing and academic
lectures i've been giving some public
intellectual lectures and interacting
with the general public uh more thinking
public and that's been a lot of fun it's
actually been very encouraging to
realize
uh how many smart knowledgeable people
there are out there in the world living
full lives
doing very interesting things but they
also have an interest in intellectual
matters and you can have a very fond
conversation with them about
nietzsche or marx or the
the current state of higher education so
i found that
uh the the tourism part that comes with
the travel and just interacting with
people that i never would have
interacted to be very pleasurable
the other big plus has been since i am a
i'm a professor i just love young
students in their first second year of
university when they realize
how big the intellectual world is and
how exciting it can be that when they
come alive intellectually
uh and then having a lot more students
from around the world who will email me
or facebook me with very interesting
questions or
they have their own podcast and when i
can i'll have a you know 45 or 50 minute
conversation with them on their podcast
so just interacting with a lot more
students from other parts of the world
than uh than i otherwise would have so
yeah well the pluses have been great the
thing is about
the public exposure and the social media
exposure that that's so interesting is
that um
the people who come to listen to you
only come because they want to listen to
you
it's really
it's a real pure form of the university
you know because there's no compulsion
as there is with say mandatory classes
and grades and so on in universities is
that that's right there is a tremendous
public hunger for philosophical
discourse that's really been
completely in some sense undiscovered up
until now and it's it's massive that's
right and that's why i think uh
optimistically i am or ultimately i am
optimistic because i think it is built
into
human nature to uh to want to be
vigorous to engage with the world and
since we're such a smart species to
engage with the world intellectually so
young people in their teens when they
are becoming
more fully aware of themselves as
independent of their parents and that
their whole life is ahead and they're
preparing for life they do have this
hunger
and it's beautiful to see it activated
yeah well obviously
all the controversy that surrounded your
work hasn't
soured you
in the least on the intellectual
enterprise it sounds like
quite the contrary well what are you
working on now like what
i know you're having a hard time writing
but like
the next five years let's say you've got
ambitions
i've carved out in my schedule starting
the end of this academic year
mid-may a significant amount more of
writing time and uh so i'm i'm making
progress and i'm optimistic that by the
end of this calendar year
i'll be uh almost on this next book what
i'm doing is uh uh
focusing on the positive the
post-modernism book is is negative the
nietzsche and the nazis book is negative
going into some dark philosophical and
political territory
uh but
to put it positively what are the
positive philosophical issues and
positions that need to be developed to
reinvigorate the enlightenment to
correct its deficiencies
to make people uh realize that the
postmodern arguments are
powerful but they're powerfully based on
some
often easy philosophical issues or
mistakes to make
uh very subtle so my value added is as a
philosopher
uh the way i'm going to in part package
this is to say that we
do have huge debates along any number of
dimensions about politics and so on but
in fact most of our debates about
politics are not at all about politics
they are about underlying
philosophical issues so you know for
example we're having debates right now
about
the proper political status of say
transgender individuals
but we're spending very little time
actually talking about the politics of
it instead we are having arguments about
human nature and to what extent things
are fixed uh causally and to what extent
things are a matter of human volition
what things are subjective what things
are objective and so on and so uh really
we are having philosophical arguments
hopefully philosophical arguments that
should be informed by biology
but even that is itself a philosophical
debate because some people want to say
we should approach this as a scientific
method type of question look at the
facts look at the experiments and others
have a more free-floating ideological
commitment that is to say they're
operating on a different epistemology so
really what we're doing is we're having
uh debates about epistemology and human
nature
not really debates about politics so the
politics is just a manifestation of that
so uh
then my my my hopeful professional
value added is to bring clarity and some
fresh perspectives on on
on those philosophical debates
one of the things that has has plagued
sorry i'll just say one more thing has
played philosophy as a whole number of
false alternatives that have been
entrenched in the discipline for
generations
and in many cases
uh if you can notice uh two apparently
opposed arguments but realize they have
a shared premise
and in often cases that shared premise
is implicit
then asking what the alternatives to
that implicit premise would be once you
make it explicit can be very
illuminating so i'm working that
territory a lot
well it's interesting you know that
maybe one of the consequences is that
out of the
let's call it
rather murky darkness of moral
relativism and
post-modernism and
the claim that power is the fundamental
motivation of human beings i mean these
are very
pessimistic philosophical statements
taken almost to
almost you would think to their logical
extreme
maybe what will happen is that out of
that will come something like a
philosophy
that's genuinely optimistic without
being naive
exactly that's nicely put
i'm reminded of a line from the roman
uh poet horus who was reflecting on some
of the skeptical and nihilistic trends
of his time uh where they were
denying the natural world denying and so
forth the lion is uh
though you drive nature out with a
pitchfork
ever she will return right so the
optimistic return is uh is what we're
working on now
right well and there does seem to be i
would say a tremendous hunger for that
you know one of the things that we were
struck by
and i'm sure you see this in your
teaching is that
it it's amazing
you know i i usually begin my lectures
on a fairly pessimistic note you know
detailing out the problems of
human nature and
society and to some degree the natural
world
trying to make a vicious case for the
for the
in some sense the atrocity of life
and
it means that there's nothing hidden in
some sense when the argument begins and
then
i try to make a case that despite that
you know we have within us the capacity
to transcend that and then that capacity
to transcend
that
the atrocity of life is actually more
powerful
and that you can derive an optimism out
of the pessimism
out of the pessimism that's even more
optimistic because of the depth of the
pessimism
you know like and you can tell students
look you guys you've got real problems
to deal with it's it's no wonder that
you're
suffering from the existential
dilemmas that you're suffering from
they're real
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
a set of viable solutions and maybe a
very large set of viable solutions that
can be that you can learn and that you
can practice and that you can engage in
that make a genuine difference to your
life and a genuine difference to the
life of the people around you and that
this is even more real than
the reality of the relativism and the
and the nihilism and the and the
pessimism and people respond
i've been aligning that especially with
the idea of responsibility you know that
it's possible to find
the sustaining meaning in your life
through the adoption of
as substantive responsibilities you can
manage and it's really quite remarkable
how
ready
people are for that idea
it really usually reduces the audiences
to silence to to speak of that
yeah well that's uh all of that touching
on the profound themes that human beings
do need to engage with
my approach is typically a different
particularly with my my first year
students where
my
reading of them is a lot of them are
coming into a university feeling
somewhat constrained sometimes they're
in university because they have to be in
university or they have the sense that
their lives are largely predetermined or
that things have been
mapped out either by their parents or
expectation of certain social forces or
whatever
and getting them to see that the world
is a lot more open
to them but there are a lot more
possibilities than that they have more
power to shape their own destinies than
they otherwise might have been taught so
uh higher education is transformative in
the sense of of liberating them from
constraints that they
uh
felt themselves to be put in
uh and i found that that has been uh
useful in tapping into the hunger that
we are both talking about because that
can be suppressed but once they get a
taste of it that in fact they are free
agents that the world is a lot more
open-ended than other people might have
been telling them they
they uh they they start to drink it up
well that was the great thing about the
university for me you know i mean i came
from a small town and went to
increasingly large universities and
every time i made a transition
the sense that the world was opening up
to me continued to increase yes it's
unbelievable and liberating that's right
and
apart that's
[Music]
makes post-modernism unsettling because
it really is a cramped intellectual
vision
but it also tends to put people into
smaller and smaller
categories right you're only a member of
this group and you're
an exemplar of it
and your identity has been shaped by
forces beyond your control and you can't
engage with other cultures and other
individuals except on the basis of
hostility which just means people
retrench so it's a very closing in kind
of intellectual movement so
the the optimism and the the romance and
the adventure and the sense that you can
in fact take charge of your own life and
make yourself and the world a better
place
uh that's the point that we need to
emphasize but of course it can't be a
naive one so we do need better
intellectual tools for that well i do
think students too like my one of the
reasons i've always loved teaching
undergraduates is because
even those who are
who have that
brittle and
let's say thin skinned
cynicism sort of the prematurely
intellectually hopeless
however they believe that this
dynamism of youth that
wants exactly to know that that call to
adventure exists and
that they will respond
with unbelievable enthusiasm
i agree entirely that's right
yeah to any message that puts
that idea across in a believable manner
and that takes them seriously like
the other thing that struck me too that
it's really saddening
you know i've i've talked to hundreds of
people
after my lectures now and
it's it's almost
inconceivable
the degree to which people are starving
for encouragement
how little they get and how little it
takes to make a massive difference in
their life just to say
you know you are a sovereign individual
of divine value the
you're the cornerstone of the community
and and and that's the fundamental
presupposition of our society that
happens to be true and that you can put
your life together with truth and
courage and things will work out better
and even more importantly than that
whether it works out or not even more
importantly than that
that is the adventure and destiny of
your life and it actually matters
and people are so
dying they're dying for that idea
yeah that's beautifully put so thanks
for saying that
well look i'd like to know when you put
up those podcasts that
respond to the criticisms of your book
so if you would be kind enough to let me
know that i will be happy to do so
absolutely well i would i would love to
publicize them it might be an
opportunity again
for us to have another
conversation um
because i'm very interested in the
criticisms you know because i i relied
on your book
a fair bit in my discussion of
post-modernism
um
it's not an area of expertise of mine
you know i was one of those academics
who tended to ignore it not entirely but
while i was pursuing my own studies but
your book was extremely useful and
you know it's not necessarily the case
that
because i'm not as philosophically
versed as i might be that
i can
evaluate all the criticisms and so i
would definitely like to know more about
that and to know more about your
response so please do let me know i
really appreciate you taking the time to
talk to me again um i always find that
it's extremely illuminating
great i appreciate the uh the invitation
and spending time with you as well it's
good fun
great and important
well good luck good luck with your
ambitions and um i wish you
even more success in the public domain
because i think that what you're doing
is extremely helpful and
oh thank you yeah you too yeah uh
the regard is mutual absolutely
all right well and hopefully we'll
have a chance to meet at some point in
the
not too distant future
perfect
very good to see you
you too
all right
bye for now bye bye